I think it's going to be powerful Kozono Exploring a good special case Don't make me
laugh xam It's
just that I'm not a brat I think
a vulnerable existence like you can touch a lot of people
hey
ban
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
I
've lost my
body for a moment, but I
'm still
asked on the right side
.
Don't underestimate me
Tick
yeah yeah yeah tar goon If my body is limited, I'll forgive you ah ah ah
tar
me
You're the newest you've ever been
voodoo
tan
What is this?  I was fueled by the expensive Tadashi
But I've already given up on knowing about water My
sister and Tsujiyoshino,
then I
'm a naughty
bastard, so I took it
easy, didn't I?
It's a lie The power and speed of this
Casiro are disappearing eeeeeeee